so I'm I have gone to I haven't gone to
the extreme servet of conservative
conservative conservative because I
would not probably be allowed into that
space when I go into places that are
that are culturally conservative I dress
culturally conservatively and I have
conversations in a respectful way I
don't always agree with what they're
having but I'm not again it's opening
the door to conversations you don't walk
into a conversation thinking you're
going to come out of it they're going to
change their mind that's not how human
relationships work it's providing an
opportunity for us to open a door where
a door was closed before and over time
building that capacity within our
embassies I keep talking about this
issue of going deep in going wide when I
talk with our folks in embassies because
for a long time as we thought about
Muslim engagement it was we're going to
go to the standard list of organizations
that are the Muslim organizations for
that country who are self proclaimed
leaders and I'm like what is what you
need to go to the people in the
in-between space the young grassroots
leaders the new the new faces the
bloggers the entrepreneurs the people
who you don't necessarily think our
leaders because that's how you begin to
open up the opportunity to hear new
ideas same thing with the conservative
the conservative groups you keep talking
and you keep building respect to keep
building dialogue and over time you have
opportunities to affect change